straight ahead on lawn crime daily
convicted sex cult leader keith raniere
ordered to pay millions to his victims
the money to pay for all past and future
surgeries for the 21 women he branded as
slaves
and harvey weinstein's defense wants
three of the 11 charges against him in
los
angeles dropped his accusers saying not
so fast
this is a message that it will cut up
catch up with you
plus a major hearing the ahmad arbory
case as three men
accused of boxing in and shooting him to
death prepare their case
we break down what the jury may and may
not hear in the upcoming
georgia jogger murder trial and the
ex-girlfriend of an accused fake uber
driver
putting the pieces together what she
says she saw in his car
after prosecutors say he stabbed college
student samantha josephson to death
over 30 times the blood she's missing
that's his car law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a sex cult leader is ordered to pay more
than 3 million dollars in restitution to
his victims
many he branded his initials into their
skin
a new york district court judge making
the ruling in a sentencing statement
for keith raniere filed in court
wednesday the judge saying rainier will
have to pay for
all past and future surgeries for the 21
women he branded as slaves
renire was the leader of the group
nexium he was convicted in 2019 of sex
trafficking and racketeering
the order will allow some of those women
to get rid of their scars the judge
writing this in his sentencing statement
quote the court finds that any lower
ranking dos slave
whose commitment to dos was secured by
collateral
and who performed uncompensated labor or
services at the behest of a dos
master is a victim of the forced labor
conspiracy offense
i spoke with survivor jessica jones
earlier this month about her decision to
blow the whistle
on the case to say the words that needed
to be said i think there's a lot of
legal jargon
and candy coding it's
that diminishes the ugliness and the
truth of what these
you know what these counts are what what
the abuse it's like you know
if you say rape molestation abandonment
like i can say these things because they
don't have
ownership over me i've transmuted those
things i am empowered
in spite of those things and because of
those things that happen
i am who i am now terry
monetary recitation and criminal cases
does come up from time to time
what do you think of the amount and the
reasoning behind it here
brian i think the amount makes complete
sense it's a little bit higher than the
restitution i've seen in other cases
but this was a very difficult case and i
think it was well deserved
restitution is for making the individual
accountable for the crime and it's also
to pay for expenses associated with the
victim
clearly here this was sex trafficking
the branding
and making sure that these individuals
can get rid of the scars
i think makes complete sense now terry
that takes care of the physical scars
what do you think about getting rid of
the mental scars as well could that be
on the table
absolutely i think that some of this
money should be used for that
when you think about it being a sex
slave that is brainwashing and
you're going to have scars both physical
and mental
so i think that going to therapy should
definitely be included
in this restitution package we
absolutely hope that those victims
can take care of both of their scars
those we can see and those we can't
thank you terry disgrace movie mogul
harvey weinstein hopes
some of the sexual assault charges filed
against him in los angeles will be
thrown out
law and crimes angela levy is here with
that and what one of his accusers is
saying after seeing him in court in los
angeles
brian harvey weinstein faces 11 sexual
assault charges in california he's
pleaded not guilty
as his accusers watch this case
incredibly closely
harvey weinstein appeared in a los
angeles courtroom
sitting in a wheelchair you can barely
see him behind his lawyers
his return to tinseltown not for a
splashy movie premiere but to face
sexual assault charges
involving five women in separate
encounters from 2004
through 2013. weinstein's lawyers have
asked that some of those charges
be dismissed we filed a dimer to
challenge three of the 11 counts on the
grounds that they're borrowed by the
statute limitations are pretty confident
the judge should grant that
the allegations attorney mark worksman
refers to involved two accusers in
incidents in 2004 2005 and 2010.
louise godbold came forward in 2017
about an allegation of sexual assault
against weinstein
years earlier i think for all of us who
for us la was the scene of the crime
it feels right that uh javi's being held
accountable
for the things that he did there godbold
is a silence breaker who now helps
survivors of sexual trauma
she's following the los angeles case
closely as she's become
friends with many accusers i will be
there
i'm going to be sure that i'm in los
angeles to support them
and to spend as much time as i can in
the courtroom to give them any kind of
moral support that i can
meanwhile weinstein's lawyers fought him
being transferred to los angeles from
new york
where he was serving a 23-year prison
sentence for sexual assault
they cite his health problems including
spinal stenosis
which they say impairs his ability to
walk
and then he add the fact that he's in
custody and
that's also deteriorating and
demoralizing as well as
physically debilitating
harvey weinstein's lawyers believe that
the prosecutors miscalculated on the
statute of limitations since they've
been expanded a few times to allow
sexual assault accusers to file charges
in these types of cases
harvey weinstein will be back in court
next week when his attorneys will argue
for that motion to dismiss
brian thanks angenet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike corobonix
now mike is the statutory limitation
argument going to be cut and dry just
calculating a few days or just something
else to it
i don't think it's going to be cut and
dry i think it's very complicated
like i said if i was good at math i'd be
a doctor and i wouldn't be an attorney
but this is very difficult in the
calculations because
number one is this has changed so many
times now there's basically no statute
of limitation in california
but prior to 2017 there's all kinds of
numbers and if it was within the
original statute of limitations
then it carries over to no statute of
limitation it's going to be very
difficult and it's probably going to be
very open
kind of argument because it's relatively
a new law that they've done with the
statute of limitations
and it's going to be difficult to
pinpoint some of these exact times that
with these
criminal acts allegedly occurred yeah i
mean
mike at the very least i've got 10
fingers and 10 toes to help you count
but
with these shifting laws i think it's
going to be difficult for anyone and
jeannette is louise godbold going to
testify in the los angeles trial
of harvey weinstein she doesn't know
yet but she has offered to do so she did
the same in the new york case but the
judge in that case didn't allow her
testimony because the allegations she
made
didn't really match up as closely with
the allegations made by the accusers in
that case but she said she is willing to
do it so
we'll have to wait and see whether or
not the prosecutors in la decide to call
her
all right well the recently extradited
harvey weinstein will be facing charges
in los
angeles we'll make sure to keep you up
to date as that case progresses
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily an ex-girlfriend takes the
stand to describe a defendant's car
after prosecutors say a woman was
stabbed to death inside
thinking it was her uber ride but first
the preliminary hearing and the trial of
three men accused of killing a jogger in
georgia
what will the october trial look like we
break it down
[Music]
next
welcome back sparks were flying in
georgia courtrooms as attorneys prepare
for the highly anticipated trial
of the men accused of killing ahmad
arbury
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael are charged with murdering
aubry while he was out jogging last
february
a third man william rhodey brian is
charged with boxing aubrey in
while filming the incident the
defendants are claiming self-defense
saying aubry was a burglar running
through their neighborhood and say
aubry's mental health records
show his response was to get angry and
aggressive
there is as i understand the state
contention that mr arbory was justified
in assaulting travis mcmichael as
self-defense on his part resisting his
legal arrest
it's essentially that he was justified
in doing what he did
um if the state is going to contend that
mr
arbury was justified in
stealing mr bryant's car or justified in
yanking them out and throwing them on
the side of the road or justified and
kidnapping or false imprisoning him
or justified and carjacking in the
second degree if they're going to
contend
that you can legally be justified in
committing various
property crimes under these
circumstances i think that's something
we probably need to flesh out
before we start trying okay
that assertion was enough to get the
prosecutor up out of her seat
and say no aubrey was trying to defend
himself against a 5 000 pound weapon the
defendant was using against him
the defendant mr bryan hit mr arbory
with his truck
that's why his palm prince on it that's
why his t-shirt fibers are on it
because he assaulted him with a 5 000
pound lethal weapon
known as a pickup truck and yes maybe mr
aubry
did try and push off that truck after
being hit with it
i get that the defense wants to
characterize that some other way
as if mr arbory was committing a crime
after being assaulted with a 5 000 pound
pickup truck a lethal weapon that could
have killed him
as mr bryan pushed him off the road
into a ditch which he by the way
demonstrated to agent seacrest
in his march 13 2020 video
it's offensive that this has been turned
into the victim was trying to commit a
carjacking
no the state is not going to argue that
he was entitled to commit a carjacking
because mr aubry was not committing a
carjacking he was not committing any
felony
mr aubry was trying to save his life
from that man who was trying to hit him
with a pickup truck
sparks flying indeed back with us is
criminal defense attorney mike corobotix
and terry austin
now as we all know these pre-trial
motions will set the arena for how this
trial will be argued
terry one of the things the defense
wants to do is argue the repealing of
the citizens arrest act
and that armory's killing was just that
how do you think
that will fare at trial you know what
the defense is trying to say
is that they were justified in the
killing in the shooting and trying to
stop aubry and they're trying to say
that he was
committing a crime whether or not he was
walking through this house
that was under construction and he was
running away or whether or not he was
trying to do a carjacking they're trying
to justify the fact
that they responded the way they did the
prosecution is basically arguing no
that's not the case here
and they're going to argue that there
was no evidence of any crime
at all whatsoever that ahmad aubry was
doing so
i think as far as the law is concerned
the citizens arrest law
it's under repeal now the governor is
about to
sign the new law and if so it's going to
totally change the way
these cases are reviewed yeah and the
interesting part is it's one thing to
say that ahmad already did
x it's another thing to say what did
they make michaels know at the time and
from what i understand
that was very little about aubrey's
actions now mike the defense wants a mod
aubry schizophrenia in the trial
why do you think they want that and will
they be successful
i don't really know why they want it and
i don't think it would be successful
i think it's pretty relevant based on
what we know
so far in this case because it doesn't
seem as you pointed out
there was any knowledge on the
defendant's
part that this young man had was
suffering from a mental disease or not
so i don't see how it becomes relevant
i think the defense needs to really
watch out here because
making these kind of arguments that
don't really seem at this point in time
to carry credibility could hurt them
into court's rulings
yeah i mean schizophrenia adhd
hunger i don't care what you're
suffering from that at that point in
time
you get chased by three men and two
trucks and and guns
i think our reactions are all going to
be the same it's going to be interesting
to see how this plays out it seems that
there's going to be another hearing
in the ahmad arbor case we'll of course
give you updates as that comes up and
anticipating a trial in this
uh the killing of a georgia jogger on
october 18th thank you for contributing
coming up on law and crime daily a legal
victory in the fight against the opioid
crisis
as big pharmaceutical companies are set
to give a major
payout to cities and states across the
country
plus a police officer's heroic act the
quick actions he took to save the people
inside this burning home the body cam
video you don't want to miss
after the break
[Music]
we're back three drug distributors and
johnson and johnson have agreed to pay
out a total of 26 billion dollars
to end legal action related to the
opioid crisis
a group of state attorney generals
making the announcement wednesday
so far at least 10 states including
texas florida and ohio
have agreed to the framework of the
agreement while many more are
considering it
the 26 billion will come from jnj
mckenson
cardinal health and amerisource bergen
the funds will go to prevention and
treatment programs and support addiction
education
once the deal becomes final thousands of
local governments and states will have
to drop lawsuits against the companies
and will have to pledge they won't file
any lawsuits in the future
the money is of course a big part of
this announcement
but we are also fundamentally changing
this industry
the distributors will fund an
independent clearinghouse to identify
red flags
so they can take action when there's a
pill mill or when a community is
drowning in prescription opioids
the distributors must prohibit the
shipping of suspicious orders
report them to regulators and terminate
offending pharmacies
all subject to the review of an
independent monitor
in addition johnson and johnson will get
out of the opioid business all together
and will not fund any organization that
promotes opioids
an upstate new york police officer is
credited for saving the lives of five
people whose house was destroyed by a
fire
i believe there's entrapment jamestown
police officer mark clonkin was on
another call
when he was diverted from a report of a
house fire this is what he saw when he
got there
where where are they well let's go let's
go
let's go conklin helped three people out
of the first floor
and then discovered a woman and her
child were on the second floor
i'm getting people out right now hey
how many people are in there he directed
both to jump into his arms
jump jump i got you i got you
incredibly no one was seriously hurt
notice the quick thinking and the
disregard for his own safety truly a
hero
when we come back blood bleach and the
murder weapon
an ex-girlfriend tells all in the fake
uber murder trial
of nathaniel roland next
[Music]
welcome back prosecutors in south
carolina are showing a jury a mountain
of evidence
they say proves a young woman was
murdered by a man after she got into his
car
thinking it was her uber ride 21 year
old samantha josephson was last seen on
surveillance video
around 2 a.m in march 2019 getting into
a black
car after leaving a bar her body was
found 14 hours later
stabbed 30 times police arrested
nathaniel roland later that day
charging him with kidnapping and murder
his ex-girlfriend says
she noticed blood on his shoes and in
his car saw him cleaning the alleged
murder weapon
just hours after the victim died
he looked shook and what do you mean by
look shook like he's seen a ghost and
how did you bang on that door hard like
the police
and what was he doing cleaning the car
like shrubbing it with something could
you tell what he was cleaning
it smelled like the car smelled like
chlorine it was bleached but it was so
strong it smelled like chlorine
did you help him clean no why not
that's not my car and while you're
driving what is he doing
cleaning the car steal still with what
like some type of wipes do you ask me
about that
yeah what you asking where do you get
them from why are you cleaning the car
with wipes
what'd he say i'm not my business and
did you see him clean anything besides
the interior of the car
this little hunter's
knife like thing what if anything did
you say to him
why would you drive that car with blood
in it any response
no she says they went to pick up her
baby and later noticed blood on the
girl's shoes
after she got out of the car days later
when she saw the murder on the news
she says she put it all together and
went to the police
i seen that she was she was missing
and then they showed the clip of his car
and what did you think when you saw the
car
it all made sense to me now what do you
mean by that
the blood she's missing that's his car
how'd you know it was his car because it
had mud on the back
about the fender on cross the defense
asked her why she initially told police
that she didn't know there was blood in
the car when she put her daughter in the
back seat
and that probably was a day that i was
tired
and wore out but when i talked to them
again
i cleared it up okay and
you told him if you had known there was
blood in the car you never would have
put her in there
is that right right and you tell him
i wanted to see if nate was going to
tell me the truth
about it with her being in the car is
that right yes did you
um know about any other
females that that nate was seeing no
so you believe that you were the only
female and you eventually find out that
he
had been talking to other females no you
didn't figure that out
mike you know me i'm always looking at a
case as a defense attorney but this
witness
her demeanor screamed credibility to me
but did what she say
persuade you absolutely and it's funny
you said stream credibility because
i was thinking when you don't
cross-examine somebody who might have
missed something
whose answer is going to be i was tired
i did just worked a double shift
i mean her credibility was was very very
strong i thought i thought she was a
great witness
for the prosecution yeah she pieced it
all together and we kind of saw
her figuring it out with the jury as
well terry where was the defense going
with this cross because
they made it seem like this mother
should have made tough choices to raise
her kid and pay the bills
and i wasn't really a fan you know i
wasn't a fan
either brian and i think it was a very
poor strategy i think the jury looked at
maria howard
believed her thought she was a good mom
she said that she
at first didn't see the blood and then
she later said she clarified that when
she realized what was going on she was
initially tired
but she made the choice to put her child
in the car
because she had no other choice she
wanted to make sure she picked her child
up
she said defiantly i'm not leaving my
child i'm definitely going to pick her
up
and she also wanted to make sure that
she made her double shift showing that
she's a
very hard worker and that she's
supporting herself she's supporting her
family
so i think attacking the girlfriend or
the ex-girlfriend
was not a wise move and i think the jury
is looking at her
as though she's a great mom she's doing
whatever she needs to do
to support her family terry i would
agree as well i think this is a great
mom and i think
mama pink would agree as well as we look
at this case
uh thank you all for contributing we'll
continue to follow the nathaniel
roland case of the law and crime network
and continue
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you